rohingya refugees living in overcrowded
camps in Bangladesh already don't have
enough to eat and it's likely to get
worse the U.N says it doesn't have the
money to pay for Food Supplies starting
from Thursday monthly rations will be
reduced to eight dollars per person the
U.N says it needs 56 million dollars to
help rohingya in Bangladesh the
government is hosting more than a
million of the minority Muslims who fled
persecution in Myanmar it says the
International Community isn't doing
enough to help
Huawei Nu is a rohingya rights activist
and she joins us now from Washington D.C
thank you very much for being on this
NewsHour I guess first of all can you
just explain what does eight dollars a
month get you I mean just how tight is
that
thank you very much
so the
for
country like yours cannot even buy a
salad a meal
and now that the refugees has to leave
a month entire month with this eight
dollars
and this is in the situations where
refugees are already
extremely at risk of malnutrition scar
businesses and other preventable
illnesses
caused by the food security
and now there is no mechanisms for the
refugees to fix
um this problem in the camps because
they are already a hundred percent
reliant on International Aid in every
aspect of their life and there is no
access to education's employment and
opportunities for skill buildings or
even to rent land so that they can
um
make their living yeah we know that this
isn't sorry to interrupt we know that
this isn't the the first cut it may very
well not be the last I mean what happens
if there are more cutbacks to to the
food
so what will happen is that it will just
increase
um it will just put them in a greater
race of risks of protections and safety
so increase
um
poverty as well as the crimes level will
leave their refugees with no choices but
to escape the camp and these Escape
ropes over land and seize a
life-threatening Rickson human
trafficking and even that
in this situations women and children
and other marginalized groups are the
most vulnerable and parents are already
thinking about sending their children to
the third country by using these means
these dangerous means so yeah this
ultimately it is it is essential that
the International Community take a
comprehensive action to resolve this
crisis and um the the food Aid card
actually revealed the system that
International Community has implemented
for these um genocide victims and
survivors to protect this genocide
victims and survivors
um it's not sustainable or effective no
well there's a 56 million dollar
shortfall I mean who's to blame for that
and where does that money come from now
it is I think where this come from it's
it's again you know it's the
international community's donors
countries the UN need to come together
come up with a comprehensive Solutions
how to address this in a way that is
effective as well as a sustainable right
um and who who does it blame for it's
the entire system that doesn't have a
proper mechanisms to provide to provide
protections for these refugees the
vulnerable as well as remember these
people are the victims of genocide there
is there is no this will just further
Exile
um like um exacerbate their their their
trauma and the challenges they face and
as well as you know it is it is
um critical that there is um to realize
this ground reality and have effective
action
solution towards this crisis thank you
so much for your time that is way way
new rohingya rights activists thank you
very much